le 27 décembre 2020 mauricette est la
première française vaccinée contre le
coronavirus après l line renaud ou
encore michel cymes à chaque fois les
photographes et les caméras sont au
rendez vous médiatiser une vaccination
ça se faisait déjà en 1957 en france et
la petite commune savoyarde de belles
entre kehl les honneurs de la première
vaccination massive vaccination massive
médiatisation massive
c'est dans ce village de 500 âmes
confime en 1957
les débuts de la vaccination contre la
poliomyélite en france tous les enfants
et les jeunes gens soit presque la
moitié de la population du village ont
reçu une dose de vaccin mis au point par
l'institut pasteur devant les caméras
les grimaces des enfants mais aussi des
sourires de stars elvis presley se fait
vacciner contre la polio devant les
caméras en 1956 résultats payant les
jeunes américains font comme lui et se
font vacciner en masse retour en france
toujours dans les années 50 contre la
tuberculose
l'êta lance le timbre antituberculeuse
un timbre pour récolter des fonds et au
passage pour faire de jolies images
d'enfants vaccinés
un nouveau né une petite fille à
l'adolescent et ses trois timbres
différents montre que le bcg doit être
appliquée et peut l'être aux différents
âges de la jeunesse autre époque les
années 90 cette fois la vaccination
devient une publicité sur le petit écran
des enfants couches culottes pour dire
non à la rougeole les oreillons et à la
rubéole
bush alors ayant rubéole pas
d'hésitation vaccination demandez
conseil à votre médecin et demander
aussi conseils aux politiques en 2009
contre la grippe a des ministres
n'hésitent pas à faire tomber la chemise
pour convaincre les français
et bien moi je le dis à chacun allez-y
c'est un geste important pour vous pour
votre famille
si le regard caméra ne suffit pas plus
surprenant la vaccination sur un plateau
de télévision
c'était en 1990 à cette époque la grippe
fait des ravages en france plusieurs
millions de malades alors pour
médiatiser le vaccin un journaliste a
osé regarder les choses par conséquent
sont faits niés la vaccination sur un
plateau de télévision ou jusqu'où l'
envie de montrer l'exemple a pu mener
[Musique]